[Musique]
je sais ce que vous allez me dire
monsieur renaud déjà sortis et quelques
jours une vidéo pour parler de l'iphone
ut pour parler d'une nouveauté de
l'iphone 8 et là qu'est ce que tu fais
pas une autre vidéo pour parler de
l'iphone 8
je suis d'accord sauf que depuis de
nouvelles rumeurs et même pas des
rumeurs des infos avéré sans sortie et
justement il fallait que je tends pas du
mal à régler l'appareil je crois sa
séquence est infâme qui règle
c'est un air frais fait beau
ces infos vienne 2000 gadget mais gadget
c'est ce blog chez moi qui a dévoilé des
infos sur ce que va être ce que pourrait
être en tout cas le prochain iphone 8
alors il perd simple mais il ya jack
nous apprend qu' il n'y aura pas trois
iphone cette année comme annoncé mais
deux iphone me gadget c'est un blog
chinois qui a des relations avec des
gens qui bossent à foxconn alors foxconn
c'est quoi foxconn c'est une énorme
boîte chinoise qui fabrique des
composants et des produits informatiques
pour des grandes marques
l'international dont notamment apple et
ce sont d'ailleurs les googles glace ils
font plein de choses et donc la foxconn
a effectivement confirmé à leurs potes
de mic gadget que ils ont commandes qui
est passé par apple pour deux nouveaux
smartphones et pas trois nouveaux
smartphones les rumeur faisait état de 1
iphone 8 un iphone 8 plus et d'un iphone
anniversaire a priori pour l'instant il
n'en sera rien il y aura un iphone 8 un
iphone 8 plus est pour l'instant pas
particulièrement des fêtes anniversaires
à moins qu'apple ait fait appel à un
autre sous traitant que foxconn ça
serait comme un univers surprenant donc
pour l'instant pas d'iphone anniversaire
ou du moins l'iphone 8 serait l'iphone
anniversaire parce qu'on imagine très
bien que là on est quoi je te fais la
vidéo on est au mois d'avril
l'iphone s'il doit sortir au mois de
septembre
il faut quand même en temps pour que
foxconn est le cahier des charges est
acquise et les matériaux qui commence la
fabrication donc ça va pas se faire en
deux jours comme ça il faut un temps il
ya un certain délai quand même donc
j'imagine mal apple fournir d'ici deux
trois mois les informations factuelles
pour construire un nouvel iphone
ceci étant dit il y avait quand même des
rumeurs qui faisaient état que les deux
iphone les deux premiers devaient sortir
à priori au mois de septembre et
troisième un peu plus tard peut-être que
tout ce qu'on aura déjà faux
dans à venir ça ferait quand même
surprenant que la ont déçu en plus que
des rumeurs parce qu'on est vraiment sur
les commandes qui sont passés par
foxconn
à moins que foxconn ne fasse pas état du
troisième du troisième téléphone et que
apple se garder la surprise
on peut toujours émettre des hypothèses
on veut toujours effectivement se poser
des questions en tout cas pour l'instant
c'est comme ça donc a priori deux
téléphones cette année deux iphone et
non pas trois
[Musique]
non
je suis dans une case en bray je suis
une vedette
à
c'était bon notamment parce qu'à
l'époque aucun sens autres infos et pas
des moindres ce que le monde aurait le
service recherche et développement
d'apple qui est située en israël qui
serait en train de travailler pour
regarder à équiper les prochains iphone
de smart connector comme on porte voix
que sont les ipad procès par les traits
effectivement de plug et ton iphone
directement sur un casque de réalité
virtuelle jetant par la dernière fois
pour moi casque de réalité virtuelle
ça doit être un accessoire indispensable
à venir sur le prochain iphone
j'avais espéré que sur l'édition 2010
est pour les 10 ans au lourd
effectivement de la vr mais a priori ce
ne sera pas le cas probablement pour
l'édition 2018 voire 2019 comme je te
lis et là ces a priori recherche et
développement donc pour l'instant rien
de rien d'officiel et aucune info qu'il
est pour l'instant vérifier quant à une
future date de sortie d'un iphone avec
des lunettes de réalité virtuelle 303
d'ici quelques années avec un mot encore
plus connectés avec de la réalité
virtuelle il ya réalité augmentée ça
pourra apporter plein de choses on peut
l'imaginer dans une consommation
quotidienne mais aussi pour tout ce qui
est business puisque les professionnels
pour les bio compte pour travailler avec
devant le but du monde pour voir ses
amis lointains
ça permettra vraiment énormément d'un
proche est là je te parle que de la
réalité virtuelle en réalité augmentée
effectivement on pourra enrichir pas
notre quotidien puisqu'on passe donc
plus on va pas devenir beaucoup d hommes
de nick notre cas on a vraiment enrichir
les choses et pouvoir avoir des objets
qu'ils auront des possibilités en
réalité augmentée on pourra imaginer
plein de choses on en reparlera plus
tard parce que ça c'est un sujet
extrêmement passionnant d'ailleurs même
ce qu'a dit à tim cook 1 le big boss
d'apple c'est que pour que tout à fait
imaginer que la réalité virtuelle et la
réalité augmentée soit une révolution
comme a pu l'être l'iphone en son temps
vraiment l'ouverture sur un autre monde
sur un nouveau marché sur quelque chose
de fondamentalement différent et c'est
en ça que ça va vraiment apporter des
choses dans notre quotidien
ça va changer les choses ça va apporter
de nouvelles applications une nouvelle
fonctionnalité pour l'instant on s'en
rend compte au travers du jeu vidéo
ça amène de nouveaux horizons mais on se
rend pas encore compte de ce savoir
pouvoir changer dans notre vie de tous
les jours et pourtant ça n'a changé
énormément de choses
[Musique]